yesterday i cut out the entire back
portion of this dress
so um but i'm not gonna show it because
i have some
there's some scabs but i just want you
know that i feel great i feel very
comfortable
[Laughter]
hi i'm trixie mattel and i'm katya and
we are hosting the 2020 youtube
streaming award
wow trixie and katya 10 years of the
streamies and they're letting you two
host this thing
what a thrill can you believe it yeah
they've really let the wheels off the
wagon at this point
tyler oakley's at some music festival
and jenna marbles quits they were like
who else
is there well talk to me about
pulling off a very different version of
the streamies in a very different
year i don't know what pulling on the
streamies looks like
i mean this year they basically were
like we want to put you guys in a moving
bus
and have you travel around los angeles
and
film and hand out awards are they gonna
let us drive
this thing hey can we drive my license
expired two years ago
you know priscilla any great drag story
starts with four wheels
yeah four wheels two hearts and one p
bag yeah and only one award which was
fake
that was kind of funny to give them to
people and then take them back and be
like you'll get it in six weeks
what's gonna surprise people about this
version of the show you guys crashing
people's houses and what antics can you
tease for me
for me what i didn't see coming was the
amount of nudity
like i knew there'd be some but i i had
no way of knowing yeah
i knew about the nudity i was surprised
by the texture
surprisingly hard because i thought
they're gonna drive around park the bus
and then let us do our little bits
um we're on the freeway yeah it was like
american ninja warrior
she's about to go for a ride holds on
it really was it was the hunger games
yeah
but enjoyable it's a little moment of
joy in a year that has not
been the most joyful for many so i'm
glad that we can wrap up the year this
way and i
wanted to hand it off to you guys give
me your list of what brought trixie and
katja joy in 2020.
nicole kidman's coats and the undoing is
a recent source of joy
i also like um you smell like a hospital
was that from a housewife to salt lake
city i said
you smell like hospitals people got in a
fight because this one girl her aunt
this one girl her aunt was dying and so
she came to visit her friend
and her friend had spent gotten 12
surgeries to have her odor glands
removed
she died on the table twice it's worth
it
and the woman who smelled like hospital
smelled like hospital because her aunt
was getting her legs amputated amputated
amputated this sounds like you where do
i stop where do i sign up for this bravo
bravo
bravo and also this one is uh alerted me
to the importance of
i wouldn't be surprised if we never saw
denise richards again
yes if you asked me we would never see
denise richards again
um making cosmetics this year listen
people are stuck at home but let me tell
you they are buying and wearing
cosmetics
that's been nice yeah oh i've achieved
up several um
a a number of personal goals um this
year actually
now that i think about it and speaking
of cosmetics we released a lipstick that
was met with
thunderous ovation sell out in nine
minutes bryce um what else our book
we had a new york times bestseller this
year we didn't even have to learn to
read if we ever get to do another book
though
then we will do our sydney prescott out
of darkness scream for
yeah tour my publicist will get killed
josh if you're here you will die yeah
and i will be moved to tears
every time by the same passage
i love the journey of uh your 2020 from
cosmetics
to mary cosby and everything in between
did you say cosby
katya had a number one electronic album
yeah six weeks ago thank you and i
at the january asked me how to play a
piano i don't even know
it's just it's all yeah and then here i
am a musical um we thought she was a
yoko
she's a john yeah wow powerful
very powerful uh honestly
being able to make youtube videos every
week has been blessed for me and i
um covet compliantly of course when to
get my lips injected with restylane
but they they messed up the needles it
was just coping oh not these lips
your hair they hear heartbeat has kind
of been on tape
that's not funny no that's not funny you
know in the words of hedwig i have to
laugh because i'll cry if i don't
trixie and i really do wish that you uh
catch the streamies this saturday
december 12th
at 9 00 p.m eastern 6 p.m pacific right
on youtube
we do look great yeah we do we look
[Applause]
[Music]
great